y
[Música]
el presidente de polo de 1100 en esquí
reiteró su esperanza de que su país se
obtenga en junio el estatus de país
candidato a la unión europea desde
francia advierten que la adhesión podría
demorar hasta 20 años a una semana de
las elecciones presidenciales de
colombia la campaña se tensa en la recta
final este domingo los candidatos
finalizaron sus intervenciones públicas
en busca de los votos indecisos y en un
ambiente cada vez más polarizado
llega a eeuu de ayuda internacional para
enfrentar el desabastecimiento de leche
de fórmula infantil y más de 30
toneladas arribaron desde europa en el
marco de la operación denominada flight
fórmula
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
france 24 en español gracias por
acompañarnos su santiago ariztía y
comenzamos esta emisión en ucrania el
presidente por los misiles que reiteró
su esperanza de que su país obtenga en
junio el estatus de país candidato a la
unión europea y su homólogo polaco andrè
ex dura de visita en quien le aseguró su
apoyo en una rueda de prensa conjunta
así es que afirmó que ucrania pertenece
a la comunidad europea desde hace mucho
tiempo la comisión europea emitirá un
informe en junio sobre se acepta la
solicitud de concretarse la adhesión de
ucrania a la unión europea podría
conllevar un largo proceso probablemente
entre 15 o 20 años advirtió el ministro
delegado francés para asuntos europeos
clima hampón y en france24 dialogamos
con aymerich durex profesor de política
exterior de francia y de la unión
europea acerca de que elementos internos
de su política y economía debería
reestructurar ucrania para satisfacer
las necesidades de la unión europea y
esto nos decía
primero habría que acabar con la guerra
porque parece imposible tener una de iun
mientras ucrania se encuentra todavía en
guerra y después hay muchos muchas
exigencias en término de democracia en
término de lucha en contra de la
corrupción porque hay tradicionalmente
muchos problemas de corrupción en
ucrania hay también la necesidad de
hacer algunas reformas en cuanto a la
consolidación en general del estado de
derecho y entonces y también en cuanto a
la economía la consolidación de la
economía de mercado y entonces es por
supuesto un proceso largo y es por esta
razón que el gobierno francés él propuso
que propone perdón una comida política
europea para tener una inclusión de
todos los estados que son candidatos
para ingresar en la unión europea y
también estados como el reino unido que
ya no hacen parte de la unión europea
para crear entonces una comunidad band
europea sin rusia pero paneuropea y para
tenerlo entonces la policía para los
estados candidatos como los estados de
los balcanes ucrania y también georgia y
moldavia que con ucrania quieren
presentar su candidatura de tener un
marco con un marco político con los
estados miembros de la unión europea y
en españa la visita de juan carlos
primero al rey emérito que se fue a abu
dhabi en 2020 tras sus presuntos
escándalos fiscales continúa generando
controversia este domingo cientos de
personas marcharon en contra del ex
monarca aunque el regreso del borbón
también ha despertado el cariño de sus
fieles en los últimos días
[Aplausos]
una visita non grata' para todos en
españa continúa la polémica por el
regreso temporal del rey emérito juan
carlos primero este domingo varios
centenares de personas se congregaron en
la capital madrid en protesta contra el
ex monarca y a favor de la república
allí cantaron proclamas en repulsa a la
figura del borbón y denunciaron que su
visita luego de cerca de dos años en abu
dhabi sea por cuestiones de ocio y no
para dar explicaciones por sus presuntos
escándalos fiscales
si es verdadera
juan carlos primero llegó a españa el
jueves para participar en una regata un
deporte del que es muy aficionado
después de que la justicia española
archivará las investigaciones en su
contra el rey emérito anunció que
regresará a su país más a menudo pese a
las tensiones que genera su presencia no
obstante a su llegada también recibió el
apoyo de sus fieles que consideraron su
vida un error histórico ha vuelto a esta
tierra a su país donde de ningún modo
debería haberse ido porque solamente el
día que marchó y me alegro profundamente
aunque juan carlos primero mantendrá su
residencia en el país del golfo su
retorno temporal ya ha vuelto a avivar
las tensiones políticas dentro del
ejecutivo y llegar a las elecciones
presidenciales de colombia del próximo
29 de mayo en france 24 estaremos
emitiendo una serie de reportajes
dedicados a estos comicios que la ven en
este informe de manuel acá no vamos a
repasar los momentos que marcaron el
gobierno de iván duque
el 7 de agosto iván duque entrega las
llaves del palacio de nariño así fueron
los eventos clave que marcaron su
mandato tras poco más de un año de
llegar a la presidencia duque hizo
frente a su primera gran crisis las
masivas protestas de noviembre de 2019
un indicio de lo que sería el estallido
social de abril de 2021 derivando en las
mayores manifestaciones en la historia
reciente de colombia la respuesta del
gobierno una fuerte represión
5 mil 340 casos de violencia perpetrados
por la fuerza pública 40 homicidios y 35
casos de violencia sexual fue lo que
vimos durante tres meses una respuesta
al gobierno muy violenta una
criminalización de la protesta social
cuatro años en donde la violencia se
expresó con muchas caras unas derivadas
de las falencias en la implementación de
los acuerdos de paz 223 masacres sólo
entre 2020 y 2022 cerca de medio millón
de desplazados desde 2018 y más de 850
líderes sociales asesinados durante el
actual mandato según indepaz
precisamente por la no implementación
del actual 2 paz comenzó a
recomponerse
la violencia dinámica de grupos armados
atentados contra líderes el covent 19
acecho al país dejando 275 personas
fallecidas por cada 100.000 habitantes
la quinta tasa de mortalidad de la
región pero con un plan de vacunación
parcialmente exitoso 70% de la población
está totalmente inoculada la pandemia
también le marcó el pulso a la economía
del país y puso a prueba la respuesta
del gobierno muy bueno lo que pasó en
términos de la respuesta y las medidas
de política económica frente a la crisis
no tan bueno diría yo decepcionante lo
que pasó en términos de la expectativa
que iba a ser un gobierno reformista y
que iba a ser digamos una serie de
medidas para continuar impulsando el
crecimiento económico y la equidad la
frontera con venezuela otra protagonista
más de un millón de personas entraron a
colombia desde 2018 una afluencia masiva
hacia un país lejos de estar preparado
pero la respuesta del gobierno fue uno
de sus logros
yo quisiera destacar de este gobierno la
continuidad que se le dio al manejo del
tema migratoria que sin duda es una de
las políticas más ambiciosas en materia
de atención social a una población con
bastante necesidad lo que transita la
recta final de su mandato cargada de
obstáculos un paro armado a manos del
grupo criminal clan del golfo que afectó
a 11 de los 32 departamentos del país y
un índice de desaprobación que ronda el
65 por ciento vamos a ver a eeuu porque
un avión de carga militar aterrizó este
domingo en indianápolis con leche de
fórmula infantil proveniente de europa
el presidente de joe biden informó sobre
la puesta en marcha de la operación
denominada flight fórmula que tiene como
objetivo a paliar el desabastecimiento
de este producto el informe es de
melissa chávez rincón
una importación especial una carga con
35 toneladas de fórmula de leche
infantil en polvo llegó este domingo a
estados unidos proveniente de alemania
será distribuida solo para bebés que no
toleran la proteína de la leche de vaca
por lo que no estará disponible en
ningún establecimiento comercial
este envío en particular se distribuirá
de inmediato en hospitales y clínicas de
todo el país vamos a ver entregas
realizadas en cuestión de días
hay varias razones de la escasez de este
producto las políticas regulatorias
estadounidenses la pandemia que generó
crisis en las cadenas de suministro el
aumento de los nacimientos en 2022 y el
retiro de una parte de la producción de
la empresa abbott tras la muerte de
cuatro niños por contraer infecciones
bacterianas presuntamente después de
consumir la fórmula el envío de este
domingo tan sólo alcanzará para atender
a 28 mil infantes durante una semana
pero representa un alivio para algunas
familias
son una salvavidas para tantos niños y
padres no solo los bebés podrán dormir
cómodamente estas noches sus padres
también al saber que tendrán comida para
proveerles en los próximos días
el presidente by den anunció que en un
segundo vuelo de la denominada
'operación flight fórmula llegará la
semana que viene según el centro para el
control y prevención de eeuu sólo uno de
cada cuatro padres alimenta a sus bebés
con leche materna el resto utilizan
sustitutos como la leche de fórmula
generando una gran demanda del producto
según las estadísticas actualmente el
desabastecimiento se encuentra en un 40
por ciento
regresamos en breve con muchas más
noticias sigan enfermas 24
[Música]